death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last
but we all die the enemy always wins and
we still need to fight him that's all I
know
you and I won't find much joy while
we're here what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight plot league
video today i am reading season 8
episode 4 i have been receiving tons of
comments from people asking me to upload
these videos as soon as possible which i
am but i also have a full-time job i
only have a certain amount of hours per
week that i can dedicate to making
videos and these videos do take a very
long time to make but I'm working as
fast as I can I figured I should let
everyone know why there are days that
I'm not able to upload something because
trust me if I could upload every single
day I would hopefully you enjoy the
direction this plot is going in so
without further ado let's begin season 8
episode 4 the opening scene is in
Winterfell smoke is rising from several
different areas of the castle the
battlements are littered with tens of
thousands of corpses most of the bodies
are burned beyond recognition the knight
king's army is gathered inside of the
castle walls now Daenerys was able to do
some significant damage to his numbers
the knight king and nearly a dozen White
Walkers are walking through the godswood
to the heart tree all of the leaves are
now burnt off the white tree is now
black with pools of some dried red
substance around the base of the
weirwood tree two of the Giants come
into the godswood and push the tree over
onto its side the knight king then walks
through the yard to head to the crypts
of Winterfell as he is walking through
the yard he picks up a weapon that was
laying on the ground it's one of the
Spears with the dragon glass tips he
looks at it almost as if he is
inspecting its properties he tosses the
spear to decide but then he puts his
hand over his chest he remembers the
children of the forest shoving dragon
glass into his own heart when the knight
King enters the crypts he heads right to
the lower level that is partially
collapsed the knight King has been here
before he knows exactly where he's going
and he looks down a tunnel that has
freshly lit with candles he knows people
escaped and he knows exactly where they
are
next in the next scene we see exactly
who was able to escape through the
secret passage
Davos Tyrion Songza bran Sam Gilly and
little Sam missandei and several others
exit the tunnel the escape route Jon had
made up led them to the white knife
River they had a few small boats stashed
on the shore that way they had faster
transportation to take them down the
river to white Harbor which is where the
rest of Danny's fleet is waiting Davos
was chosen to lead the party if they
ever had to use this plan he knows the
waters better than anyone the map says
to wait at Wade harbour until they can
regroup Davos tyrion and sam pull the
two boats into the water and begin
loading everyone into them none of them
know who is still alive
they went straight for the tunnel as
soon as the horn was blown Davos doesn't
even know when Jon are Daenerys will
meet them at white Harbor all he knows
is that's where he was told to go as
Davos and Sam go to left-brain into the
boat they noticed that he's not exactly
conscious his eyes are rolled back into
his head and his hands are still
gripping the chair sam says he'll be
fine this isn't the first time he has
seen brain do this Davos and Sam have to
unlock his grip from the chair to get
him into the boat Daenerys Jon Jamie
Barrack the Hound Brienne arya ginjury
and a few others land at white Harbor
John says everyone else who escaped had
a good head start so they should be
reaching the river sometime soon john
wants to leave the injur here then fly
up the river in hopes of locating his
family
Daenerys voices her concern for a goal
she hasn't seen him since he flew off
after he was hit Jamie tells John he
will go with them although he did suffer
some injuries trying to help Arya he
doesn't just want to sit by while others
are heading back out into dangerous
territories John gives Jamie a nod and
thanks him for helping him save his
sister John says I need to get the rest
of my family out of the north
immediately he says Winterfell is gone
along with most of our men we are going
to need more help if we're ever going to
stop the night king we can't allow him
to take King's Landing even if your
sister is the one who is ruling there
Tyrion said there is a million people
living there now
if the night King turns that many people
we have lost we need to talk to your
sister she must understand we need the
golden company and we may need
protection behind those walls we are
running out of options
sir in the next scene Theon and his men
prepared to head for King's Landing now
that it's beginning to get dark outside
they know the iron fleet will be sitting
in the bay they just need to slip in
grab your ax and get the hell out of
there before anyone's alerted as Theon
and his men walk across the beach they
notice a shadowy figure sitting in their
boat
Theon is stunned when he sees who is
waiting for them it's the spider Varys
there are no other boats in sight and
Varys is completely dry they have no
idea how he arrived at Dragonstone
when Theon asks Varys why he is here all
he says is I'm coming with you back in
King's Landing Qyburn meets what Cersei
and Euron to tell them about some recent
reports he has been receiving through
his little birds
Qyburn tells them that Daenerys
Targaryen fleet is at white Harbor she
has abandoned Dragonstone while they
battle in the north her fleet is the
only means for transporting her large
force quickly they know John said the
army of the Dead cannot swim so Cersei
doesn't want to allow John and Daenerys
to have a way to flee to the sea so
Cersei tells urine to take some pots of
wildfire to white Harbor and burn all of
their ships
Euron says I will do this but not until
after I spend another night in the red
keep in the next scene bran opens his
eyes after he comes out of his visions
Sam is sitting next to him and he asks
Brian if everything is okay Brian had
been out of it for quite some time and
his hands are starting to callus from
the way he keeps gripping onto his chair
brian says he's fine but he doesn't
quite understand why he saw what he saw
this time sam says what did you see was
it the night king is he getting close to
us again brain says no then he looks at
Gilly and he says I saw your son little
Sam
he was crying and surrounded by fires
everyone on the boat looks very
concerned by the tone of branes voice
Gilly wraps her arms tightly around her
son Davos tells Gilly not to worry
they will be a white Harbor soon enough
then they can get them on a ship and out
to the sea and get far away from here
brand says we won't be getting on any
ships John is coming to get us now then
he looks back to Gilly and says does
your son like dragons Gilly doesn't even
want to look at bran
but then a dragon appears it has a big
hole in its right wing Ragle seems to be
following them down the river back at
white Harbor Daenerys John and Jamie
prepare to leave at dawn so they can
find the rest of the survivors John
tells barrack in the Hound to find some
food and make sure everyone gets
something to eat they might not have
many chances after they leave Arya helps
brie and clean out the wound in her leg
and get it wrapped up one of the whites
buried a sword deep into her thigh she
can barely stand let alone fight the
Hound walks over to Arya and Brienne and
he says I hope you aren't asking her for
mercy because she won't give it to you
most men would die from a wound like
that but I'm sure you will have your
foot in someone's ass in no time the Sun
is starting to come up John and Daenerys
and Jamie walk over to climb on drug on
John looks back to arya and says if we
aren't back by sundown all of you need
to take one of the ships to Dragonstone
the night king's army won't be able to
reach you there we need to find songs of
brain and the others as soon as possible
then get everyone out of here
John and Aria hug then he climbs on drug
on and they head up the river in the
next scene you're on in Cersei or laying
in bed together Cersei is still asleep
but you're on and starting to wake up he
rolls over and looks at Cersei he starts
to run his finger across her lips then
he moves his hands further and further
down until it's under the blankets
Euron puts his hand between Circe's
thighs and he can feel a wetness on his
fingertips he pulls his hand from under
the blankets and he can see they are
covered in blood urine rips the blankets
off Cersei and he can see that most of
the bed is covered in blood also Cersei
wakes up when she feels the cold air hit
her naked body she can see you're on
standing over her with a strange look on
his face
Cersei then sits up and is completely
horrified by what she has seen she
begins screaming and crying the mountain
comes into the room with his sword drawn
expecting to see
garcy in a struggle Euron puts his hands
up but the mountain walks where he past
him he grabs one of his sheets and
wrapped Searcy up then he carries her
out of the room
Euron gets dressed and he leaves the
room with a twisted smile on his face as
he is walking across the throne room one
of the Lannister guards walks up to him
and tells him there is something he
needs to see they go outside and walk
down to the water
when Euron gets closer to the bay he
stops in his tracks and he has a look of
shock on his face almost all of his iron
fleet is gone
the silence is still there but that's
about it Euron quickly boards the
silence
there are several men on the deck with
their throats slit when Euron enters the
main cabin he can see that Yara is gone
there is a dagger sticking into the wall
with a note pinned under it all the note
says is what his dead may never die
Euron pulls the dagger from the note and
then he turns to the Lannister guard he
calmly says to the guard
how does someone sneak into the bay and
make off with an entire fleet before the
man can mutter a single word you're on
jams the dagger into his throat
Euron leaves the silence and walks back
into the city Yohan meets with a few men
of the city watch they then head to the
chambers where the commander of the
golden company is staying when they
enter the room it's completely empty he
tells the captain of the city watch to
gather up all of his men and find the
golden company check every brothel every
Inn or anywhere else they might be the
city watch enter every house or
establishment within the city the golden
company is gone along with most of the
Ironborn men that weren't killed on the
ships
Joran is furious he orders the captain
to bring him every man that was on watch
last night
these men were extremely incompetent or
they were paid off
either way they will all be killed back
on Dragonstone Theon has dozens of men
getting as much dragon glass out of the
caves as possible then they are leaving
again and going north
Theon now has an entire fleet with over
20,000 men they will need to arm as many
as possible with dragonglass
when Theon exits the cave he walks over
to Yara who is standing on the beach
Theon looks at Yara for several moments
in his
I start to fill up with tears Yara has
blood and bruises all over her still and
Euron had her tongue removed
Theon says Yara I am sorry I'm sorry I
left you and I'm sorry for what he did
to you I I'm sorry
Yara steps forward and wraps her arms
around Theon to embrace him she is still
thankful to be alive Baris in a
commander of the golden company are
standing on the beach also the commander
shakes varus's hand and says it's good
to see you again my old friend he says
Ilario told me you would come for us but
I wasn't sure if you were still alive
before they can finish their
conversation they spot several ships
approaching the beach all of the men on
the beach begin to scramble for their
weapons
it takes Varys a few moments to
recognize the banner waving on the ship
when it stops flapping in the wind Varys
has a fearful look on his face the
banner is displaying the flaming heart
Melisandre and can vara have arrived
Melisandre and convar walk onto the
beach and begin to approach Baris the
red rubies they are wearing on their
throats or glowing brighter than ever
Melisandre says hello dear spider can
vara places a hand on varus and she says
do we still serve the same queen Varys
nods his head in kinvaras as good you
are coming with us
all of you must come with us it's time
we play our final part in the war
darkness has fell over Winterfell the
king and the Queen will be back at white
Harbor soon but that's not where we're
going
Varys you must ride with us tell your
men it's time to leave in the next scene
Daenerys John and Jaime spot regal in
the sky above the river there are a few
small boats below him they have found
Songza bran and the rest of the
survivors ray gall and rogue on both
begin to cry out to each other and Davos
tells everyone they're going to the
shore John and Daenerys are here John
embraces his family when they exit the
boats they begin to load everyone on the
back of drug on and fly back to white
Harbor to regroup what the others before
they take off brand tells John when they
get to white Harbor they need to speak
there is
much time left back at white harbor area
and ginjury began telling everyone to
prepare to leave it's starting to get
dark outside
John said if they aren't back by sundown
we need to board a ship and go to
Dragonstone the night King might be
heading this way as we speak we cannot
stay here long beric Dondarrion stands
up and says they're here both dragons
come up from behind them and they land
they rush over to see who has made it
out of Winterfell alive they start
helping everyone off of the Dragons and
when arya sees Jamie she says thank you
for helping my family then she reaches
out the shake hands John helps brain
down and says let's talk bran says do
you want to speak in private and John
says no if there is something I must
know just say it everyone starts to look
at John and bran and Sam already knows
what's about to come next brain says
John you're an exactly who you think you
are there is a great power in you that
you never knew you had but I'm sure
you've always felt it why do you think
you rose from the dead why do you think
you found the direwolves why do you
think my father never told you who your
mother was
John you have the blood of Ice and Fire
you are the Song of Ice and Fire the
three-eyed Raven showed me your birth it
wasn't just so I could see who your
parents were it's because you are the
one who will have to bring the dawn
every time I try to look for answers
about how to defeat the night king all I
see are images that point to you Ned
Stark is not your father you are the son
of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark
you are the one who is destined to
defeat the night king but we must act
fast these revelations shock everyone
who is listening there are nearly two
dozen people with all of their eyes on
John everyone is silent
John is struggling to process everything
that bran has just said to him Sam steps
forward and says it's true he pulls out
a rolled-up parchment from his pocket
and he hands it to John it's the record
of regards annulment with Elia Martell
in the secret marriage in Dorne brain
says you've never been ambassador John
you are the
legitimate heir to the Iron Throne your
true name is Aegon Targaryen this new
revelation stuns Daenerys Targaryen her
eyes are filling up with tears and she
places her hand onto her stomach Sansa
and Arya are at a loss for words brain
says I know all of this must be hard to
grasp right now when all of this is over
you will know that it's the truth
finally John says something he starts to
shake his head and say none of this
makes any sense
why wouldn't follow tell me brain says
your mother made him promise he couldn't
allow anyone to find out who your father
was Robert Baratheon would have killed
you Robert loved Liana but she didn't
love him
Rhaegar never kidnapped Liana she loved
him and together they had Jiu Rhaegar
said you would be the Song of Ice and
Fire that day has finally come there is
one more thing you must do in order to
stop the night king you will kill him
John but it won't be here it's time to
go the night King has left Winterfell
and he's coming for all of us everyone
begins to walk away so they can get on
one of the ships bran tells everyone to
stop it will take too long if they
travel by ship they will need to fly
there brain says we must go to the
Trident I have seen the battlefield in
my visions the lady in red will be there
Daenerys says Melisandre she then says I
won't be able to fly everyone Daryl and
you're gone there is too many people and
Rhaegar won't let them on without a
rider Daenerys and brand both looked to
John brain says you are a Targaryen John
you must believe there is power in you
and you need to embrace it do not deny
it
Daenerys says he's right John I should
have known by the way drug on bonded
with you immediately
Viserion died trying to save you
I named ragle after my brother your
father it must be you that mounts him
John knows they have no other choice so
he walks over to Rago and he walks right
up to his face and he begins to pet him
John begins to whisper something to the
dragon then he slowly walks around him
and
on top when John sits down raiga lets
out a scream so loud that little Sam
begins to cry ray gall stretches out his
wings and flaps them a few times Sansa
and Arya can't believe what they are
seeing but before anyone has much time
to react John yells down let's go
half of them climb on drug on with
Daenerys and the rest get on with John
they take flight and head straight for
the Trident in the next scene you're on
enter sky burns lab room he had been
examining Cersei after she miscarried
Cersei lost a significant amount of
blood Qyburn was keeping her sedated
with one of his potions your until
Cersei what has happened
most of his fleet is gone the Ironborn
are gone the golden company are gone
Euron says he has no reason to stay in
the city
Cersei doesn't have enough Lannister men
in the city watch to hold King's Landing
he's taking the silence and leaving
Cersei says wait she sits up and says I
thought you said you were a king you
promised you would never abandon me and
now you want to leave because we lost
some men in boats we haven't lost yet I
still have one thing they do not
Daenerys said the army of the Dead is
100,000 strong have patience the dead
will crush our enemies for us Daenerys
already lost one dragon she will lose
the rest King's Landing is
well-protected no one will enter through
our gates even if they somehow managed
to breach them there won't be a city
left to rule the plans were already set
in motion before you arrived now you
said you wanted to rule Westeros
together and crush our enemies together
you say you need a queen at your side
but you are only king of the Iron
Islands how about a make you a true king
and together we can watch all of our
enemies burn alive all right ladies and
gentlemen that is the end of episode 4
it's looking like everything is going to
explode in episode 5 which kind of makes
sense because the episode right before
the finale are usually the biggest in
terms of production Miguel supports Nik
will definitely have his
hands-full if he has to direct something
like this let me know how you felt about
the episode put all your thoughts and
questions down below I want to give a
special shout out to everyone that has
been signing up to my patreon the amount
of support I received in the last two
weeks has been absolutely crazy and I
cannot thank you all enough
I'm almost making enough to be able to
make youtube videos full-time I'm
getting closer and closer to the goal on
patreon so I just wanted to take an
extra few moments to tell everyone how
much I appreciate that I hope everyone
has a great day and I hope to see you
all come back for episode 5 I will see
you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]